so I cannot get enough of Pedro Pascal
right now Mandalorian Last of Us this
man is just killing it left and right he
has been crowned the internet's dad with
an official crowning ceremony TBD and I
am so here for it Eddie Pascal
Papi Pascal honestly it's hard for me to
think that there was a world before
Pedro Pascal was famous what were those
days like pre-2014 what did we do just
watch Downton Abbey Sherlock and then
cry afterwards because there was just
some hole in our Collective souls okay
like don't get me wrong Pascal was doing
some great work before his big breaks
and we'll cover some of the best in a
bit but things really didn't take off
until he landed the role of Oberyn
Martell in the biggest show out there
Game of Thrones think that the trick to
Game of Thrones was only doing one scene
where your life ends tragically just
compare how much we love Sean Bean Jason
Momoa and Pedro Pascal versus pretty
much everyone else who stuck it out till
the end and then did awful movies like
eternals or Terminator Genesis he showed
real Superstar skill in only like a few
scenes and one epic fight scene against
the mountain that still has me
traumatized to this day honestly he was
the internet's Underdog but he wasn't
quite the internet's Dad yeah being the
underdog was like enough to land him a
lead role on narcos and a couple of
movie roles that like paid the bills but
things were not on that Oberyn level you
know luckily his bestie had the greatest
advice for him that he'd ever get note
to self when Oscar Isaac tells you to do
something always do it so let me take
you all the way back to 2005 when the
most glamorous thing in all of human
history happened Pedro Pascal and Oscar
Isaac met they were both in an
Off-Broadway play called the beauty of
the Father which sounds pretty bad to be
honest from what I've heard Oscar Isaac
played a ghost that none of the other
characters could see so Oscar would try
to get the entire cast to like crack up
and forget their lines and no one else
on stage could even acknowledge his
presence and after they did that
presumably horrible play that barely
paid them they stayed besties as the two
separately got famous though Oscar Isaac
got famous much faster to that point
Pascal went to his old pal who was well
versed in the franchise game by that
point and asked him if he should join a
little TV show set in the Star Wars
Universe called the Mandalorian and
let's just say he was not sold on this
weird show where he'd have to hide his
face most of the time and where he'd be
upstaged by a puppet we don't exactly
know what Oscar said but I imagine that
he punched him in the gut and said do it
they have that kind of Little Brother
Big Brother rivalry kind of friendship
and apparently there's a long-running
argument over who would win in a fight
between Mando and Moon Knight and who do
you think it'd be the answer to that
question is we would win if Disney ever
let that glorious thing happen we would
win so the Mandalorian was exactly the
show the world needed to get us to the
pandemic right I think we've all just
like collectively agreed that Tiger King
just didn't happen really sorry Carol
Baskin glad your ex-husband is alive but
Mandalorian had all of the Star Wars
action everyone loved and honestly it's
the only Star Wars project everyone's
agreed on since we all agreed to never
speak of the the holiday special the
stoic dingarin with the adorable baby
Yoda and I'm never calling him grogu was
just such an iconic father and adopted
child Duo it was the wholesome action
that we like all needed right and truth
be told the Mandalorian wasn't quite
enough to make him the internet's dad
not yet not because he didn't earn it
but because the competition was fierce
we had Timothy Oliphant the handsome
Space Cowboy and mount the handsome
space captain and we still had Chris
Evans as Captain of all of America and
not to mention that Robert Downey Jr
literally gave his life for his own
daughter's future sorry Iron Man that's
like the most dad thing ever so Pascal
needed one more kid to save in order to
take him over the top that's when he did
The Impossible and beat out freaking
mahershala Ali AKA can make me cry with
his acting in half a second flat for the
role as Joel In The Last of Us his
chemistry with Bella Ramsay the fact
that he can't run up a flight of stairs
without passing out and that
traumatizing first episode seriously
sealed the deal for Pascal all that was
left was for tick tock to formally
declare its undying love for him and boy
did it find a lot to love to me the
greatest thing that tiktok has like ever
done is dive through Pedro Pascal's
early career to find the sexiest things
he's done like it's Indiana Jones
looking for a Priceless Relic I'm
talking about the sexy compilation from
kingsman the Golden Circle his vampire
Cameo on Buffy the Vampire Slayer and
this beautiful performance he gave as
the gothic criminal cult leader from
NYPD Blue like just imagine what every
scared middle-aged man thought goth
people were like in the early 2000s and
that's what this character was now if I
was in charge of the met this would be
the only exhibit it's glorious now that
James Gunn needs a new Batman who finds
out that he's also a dad to a little
psychopath I think I got somebody for
the job Pedro Pascal for Batman make it
happen internet
foreign